Dear diary,
Everything in my life is changing.
My best friend Justin is moving to Alabama.
And my mom's got a boyfriend. It's weird.
Can I have a donut?
How would you like a protein smoothie?
Did you stay overnight?
Okay, fine! You can have a donut!
Yes!
Can you just give him a chance?
He's a sports car.
A what?
A phase.
Just saying.
Hey, dad. I was just thinking of you.
I'm sure mom's told you.
I'm moving back.
I'm so glad you're coming home.
I love that you're doing your art.
But you know, you also need people.
Friends are good to have.
Hi,
I'm Brandi with an "I"
are you starting middle school
at Park Ridge tomorrow?
Did you make any new friends?
I think so.
You wanna sit together... for lunch?
Yeah!
Good news of the day,
dad comes home.
Dinner is served!
And Stanley knows my name.
Hey, Stanley.
Oh, hey, Amber!
He'd be even luckier if he got to know you.
Ouch!
That was loud.
I wish they'd stop moving that pillar!
Don't look back!
Oh, right. Okay.
I don't want to feel guilty
for being happy.
How do you decide whose happiness is most important?
Phil.
Max.
Sarah.
Honey.
-Yeah?
-Yes?
This is like a movie and I'm an extra in it.
This is serious.
I know.
The movie is gonna be a drama. Duh.
Mom, I'm sad.
Happy times won't last forever.
But neither will sad times.
We'll never, ever love anyone as much as we love you.
So, can I get a dog?
I see what you just did there.
♪♪